I'm stage four so my cancer came back
and that's why I'm here I mean I'm
petrified I'm pretty scared shannen
doherty reveals her breast cancer has
returned the Beverly Hills 90210 star
opened up to Good Morning America's amy
robach a breast cancer survivor herself
about fighting the disease for a second
time I don't think that I've processed
it it's a bitter pill to swallow and a
lot of ways it's not pheromone I may
swear I say why me and then I go well
why not me who else you know who else
besides me deserves this none of us do
Shannon was originally diagnosed with
breast cancer in February 2015 and she
later entered remission but now she's
revealing that she's been privately
fighting this battle for almost a year
which means she was living with this
news while preparing to film the reboot
bh9 oh two one oh and found out that her
longtime pal Luke Perry had died of a
stroke was so weird for me to be
diagnosed and then somebody who is you
know seemingly healthy to go first it
was really like shocking and the least I
could do to honor him was do that show
the 48 year old actress said she hopes
her work on the series shows that people
with stage 4 cancer can work you know
our life doesn't end the minute we get
that diagnosis we still have some living
to do Shannon's rock throughout it her
co-star Brian Austin Green the only
co-star Shannon says she told Brian was
the one person who of that group of
people that knew prior to shooting he
would always call me and say listen you
know whatever happens like I have your
back
making matters worse Shannon is also
knee-deep in another fight a lawsuit
against her insurance company State Farm
after her home was damaged during the
California wildfires in 20
et has reached out to State Farm for
comment they said quote we empathize
with mr. D's health issues and wish her
a full recovery we strongly believe we
have upheld our commitment to our
customer and have paid what we owe on
this claim we are prepared to defend our
position in court Shannon said her
decision to speak out about her stage
four cancer diagnosis is only because
court Doc's detailing her health
conditions will be made public ahead of
the trial and I'd rather people hear
from me I don't want it to be twisted I
don't want it to be a court document I
want it to be real and authentic and I
want it I want to control the narrative
I want it I want people to know from me
Shannon was especially tearful when it
came to talking about her loved ones
when she opened up to et in 2016 she
praised her mom and her husband for
staying by her side throughout her first
bout with cancer she's so strong my mom
is like you know she's still 9 no Lea
she's a southern girl and she puts on
this very brave strong face with me you
know her my husband and tag team it's
like this amazing you know they really
come together to take care of me most
impressive of all Shannon's resilience
and positive mindset do you believe that
everything truly happens for a reason
you know I still am searching for that
reason yes I think it's to help people
but I think it's something bigger and
and I do believe that you know God will
show me what that is at some point and I
just have to trust I want to stay
positive and I want to believe that if I
if I fight and I take care of myself
that I'm gonna be okay
ET is wishing Shannon all the best and I
certainly admire her determination and
her passion for helping others till next
time I'm Deidre Behar thanks for
watching
[Music]